yeah and I that's what I wanted to start
by saying is I'm sure everyone who's
listening um thank you for how diligent
and
regular you were with like keeping a
community alive for stand up and really
pushing the community to come together
regularly during the pandemic with all
things stand up with the hot breath
averse with the writing sessions and the
writing prompts I know I did it multiple
times and it uh very commendable and
thank you for as I'm sure a lot of
people I think were starting off as new
Comics who are now three years into
doing comedy and kind of their starting
place was with you because they had just
gotten into doing it live and they
didn't want to let it go and then you
ushered in a way to keep on doing it
oh wow well wow thank you so much Ricky
wow
yeah it was a it's it's wild to now be
back out in the lot in like in the wild
and seeing
different um like I'm starting to meet
people from the hot breadth of verse now
that like we only knew each other online
and now we're starting to do shows
together and I mean I'm going up to
Virginia on Friday to do a gig with uh
someone on the hot breadth of verse that
I met during the pandemic it's like it's
kind of wild and crazy how it all has
come together like this
yeah and that but that's
kudos to you though you're the one that
kept it going and didn't let it falter
and I I'm sure you not to be
melodramatic you saved a lot of people
who who needed that outlet and needed
that community that kind of um comedy
family at that time oh wow thank you so
much Ricky I really appreciate you
saying that I really
it all just kind of it all just kind of
happened and it's it's still happening
which I'm so grateful for now that
people even with the pandemic and people
out and about now people still care and
people still like participating are
still active so it's um it's a it's a
it's a community effort for sure
but thank you for saying that that makes
my heart smile 100 honest and true with
saying it not not trying to Glad hand
you
glad hand oh I haven't heard that one
before that's an old timey term like
Scuttle button
[Laughter]
based on this dank like dark light I'm
not sure if people can tell uh my age
they're like is he 50 is he 37 I'm not
sure why does he know these terms
I love I say Heaven's the Betsy I said I
venture to say on my my wife's walk
yesterday morning I said I venture to
say we got some of the best blooms in
the in the neighborhood
you Southern gentlemen
that's that old um a game show sketch
that I wanted to write when I was uh
heavy into sketch comedy was a game show
called Southern gay or Baptist
when you had to guess
if the gentleman caller was Southern gay
or Baptist and then the the reveal would
be at the end one of the contestants was
all three oh that's a great twist yeah
oh wow and people are echoing your um
your kind words and the
in the live chat here so that's nice
that's if people haven't um taken the
time they've they've started doing the
hot breath of Earth during the pandemic
yeah they definitely should should give
you the props that's deserved I know you
said about meeting people in real life
there are people via Twitter or Facebook
that I've talked to that were from the
hot breath averse in the writing prompt
the daily writing prompts that like I'll
see their names and I'll be like oh my
god I've known them for like three years
now and then I'll be like how do I know
them did I meet them in person like no
they are the writing prompt people that
like
would would everybody would give each
other tags or you know give a thumbs up
and just like a pat on the back and
support our dumb weird ideas when
we didn't have that ability to do it in
person it was that hang before and after
shows
that like
yes we missed doing shows
but that hang and that human interaction
I know for me
nothing beats the if you're driving like
a caravan of whoever the show is if
there's like three of you on the show
nothing's better than that drive to and
from the venue like the show for me like
the show it's fun it's great I love to
entertain the audience but like the
workshopping and like the Synergy of
ideas and stuff amongst the comedians
it's it's the travel
yeah and that that communion that
support I think is something I didn't
really have
early on of that much like camaraderie I
guess in comedy so I try to be more
Mindful and intentional about it now
because it is comedy can be a lot of
competition and very negative so it's
good when people are just the contrary
to that unfortunately it's very
territorial in a lot of areas
um and places
but it doesn't need to be like it needs
to be a relay race it needs to be people
supporting each other and passing off
the Baton and like great yes okay I was
just on stage or someone coming on after
me I hope they do better like I hope
their time and their yeah I've I've
never understood
the competitive nature of Comedy which
is to entertain the audience but that's
my biggest gripe I don't know if we
talked about it in our our other episode
together is comedians who are um
striving to show you how funny they are
instead of going on stage trying to
entertain the audience that being there
like first and foremost
objective is
entertain the audience that doesn't mean
necessarily make them laugh it's just
entertain them so be prepared be willing
to not berate them if they're not giving
you the response you think you deserve I
mean how many shows first show on a
Friday do you go up there and you don't
get a response and you're like [__] I
must have really sucked
and then after the show people are
leaving and they're like oh my God
you're so funny and I've been like
okay it'd be nice of you to laughed but
I get it you're tired it's the first
show Friday and yeah and each each crowd
has a different temperament they have a
different level of laughter they're
going to be giving and I think that's
something young comics
early on I mean I would do this as well
as if like if it doesn't kill
then you can like turn on the audience
or blame the audience or if a joke
doesn't work at all it's all of a sudden
the audience's fault like that is if you
ever I have never seen it serve a comic
in a positive way
like so many that's like that knee-jerk
thing to do I'm I'm saying like as as
experienced Comics or as new comics to
be like well that joke's a lot funnier
like
you know what an audience loves to hear
is that they're a bunch of dum-dums
they're not picking up what you're
putting down like I've never seen it in
the history of like ever seeing a show
I've never seen an audience get berated
for not laughing at something and then
the comic
earn their trust or earned them on their
side for the rest of the show
yeah especially especially a young comic
like especially I've seen like more
seasoned Headliners like clubs and stuff
who will say something but I mean
they're experienced enough to like make
it part of their act and not they sold
their ticket because they came to yeah
they came to see that person yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're notoriety in
their credits and blah blah blah yeah
yeah sorry many many tangent but yes
thank you for keeping the hot breakfast
going even people did things during
covid that then after kovid stopped
because the World opened back up and we
got to get on stages again in front of
people you have you have kept us going
and that is quite admirable as well
well thank you thank you so much Ricky
and thank you to everyone you chewed
your own adulation
oh yes no no please please keep it gay
yeah yeah I'm like it's too much it's
too much and I keep hitting the Applause
sound effect
I love that yeah and thank you for
everyone watching live or listening to
the podcast after we do these live
streams every Tuesday and it's like live
q a where you can ask questions or if
you want feedback on a joke you can post
that as well but I think our first
episode together Ricky it was July of
2020 and you had just released an album
I think you had just filmed your dry bar
special
um which I have since also I filmed one
I don't know when it's coming out but no
one does it seems like it's all that
seems to be just like it'll be when it's
bees
and so um I think you know Glenn tickle
as well of course I saw him in the live
chat here yeah oh is he oh what question
what burning searing questions does Mr
tickle have
um probably just comments of of saying
how lovely of gentlemen we are
um
but he as well as I you live in that
limbo when it comes to dry bar nothing
beats though at least uh in my
experience the
the warmth and the professionalism that
you you get treated to while you're
filming are special oh dude
the best
yeah
and so it's hard than when you don't
know and you're in that limbo of when is
it gonna come out because you've talked
it up to so many people you've heard
stories of some people's specials
getting shelved and you're like that
girl that's waiting to get uh asked out
to prom
uh you're like I know it's gonna happen
and I know prom is gonna happen but I I
don't know when this is gonna happen and
it's that's the that's the hardest thing
with like auditions and stuff too but
I'm sure yours is uh did you did you
wear a suit
uh no I didn't wear a suit oh my my
first my self-produced special I wore a
suit so this one I was trying to dress
down and be a little more like trophy
trophy husband right trophy husband yeah
yeah yeah fantastic if you haven't it's
out
um on YouTube Correct uh I'm so I sell
it on my website I didn't go to YouTube
special route yes I saw it when there
was a possibility of it being available
for freezies back in the day but yeah
it's very possible yeah if if you if you
haven't seen it please go and watch it
um Joel is a consummate professional and
you are one of the people that I saw
wearing a suit
that I was like you know what I like
dressing up like I feel good and I like
get an extra bit of Confidence from it
so um I'm filming a special my second
special in April and I asked the
producers I was like
wear sweater and like a pair of khakis
and I sent them a picture of a couple of
I sent them some clips I was like or a
suit and they were like suit and I was
like good like I didn't want to feel
pretentious but like I feel good
dressing up like I don't know what it is
about it there's like either like um
like a Lenny Bruce like old school kind
of vibe to it or something I don't know
what it is like I've really embraced for
bigger shows wearing a suit and feeling
like really nice about myself
yeah
I don't know
if we had um Joe lowers he's the CEO of
World Series of comedy comedy festival
and um maybe we were talking about it on
there of like how Comics a lot of comics
will dress like very like dingy on stage
and it looks like they just got out of
bed and it's like if that's your thing
cool but otherwise it's like you want
the audience to feel like they're you
know they're getting a show like they're
getting if you want to be a professional
you almost need to be perceived as that
even if you aren't a professional comic
yet I think how you dress really really
impacts the effect of your jokes and
also just the confidence of your
performance like you said if you if you
look good you like you feel good I think
Deion Sanders said if you look good you
feel good you feel good you play good
you play good they pay good
bam I think it's all about yeah it's
mental perception and that's right off
the bat of like even when you hit the
stage how you grab the mic do you move
the mic stand do you might move it out
of the way do you get in the audience
face do you sit back
everything within that first 30 seconds
is a microcosm of what the rest of your
set is going to be and the tone that
you're setting for the rest of the 30
minutes 20 minutes half and whatever
your set is headliner feature MC
you're really
like subconsciously to a lot of the
audience you're telling them okay this
is who I'm going to be for the rest of
this time whether that's who you really
are whether that's if you've even found
your voice I know that's the hardest
thing with comics
so like if if I'm doing like a real
small room in like a brewery or
something
um
or Vineyard I tend to not wear a suit I
tend to wear what I call like a dad
sweater not a Cosby sweater but like
a middle age like Millennial dad sweater
because I feel comfortable wearing that
and if I'm doing like a theater or
something I tend to wear a suit because
for both reasons like I respect
the audience and like why they came
there uh I I've said this a ton but I
think an audience gives you gives a
performer way more than the performer
gives before the performer utters a word
whether it's a free show whether whether
it's a paid show they gave you their
time so you like you owe them to try to
entertain them if
for me as an audience member if I smell
that a comedian is trying to show us
that he's funny I'm immediately turned
off
mm-hmm
how do they what do you mean by that
so like there's sometimes and it goes
hand in hand with like if a comedian
doesn't get the response from from a
joke that they think they deserve that
they make a comment like that that's a
real big signifier of like the comedian
I don't know if it's fake confidence
in their working new material or like
that's what they do to the the bragado
show kind of um
just the kind of essence they're trying
to portray
but like
I for again it's for me personally but
I look at comedy in a very wide scope of
from like the vaudevillian comics
to you know circus performers to variety
performers I don't put myself in a box
and I don't put any other comedians in a
box of what I think stand up
quote-unquote should be which I think is
the funniest
social media argument of like Hannah
Gatsby that's a one-person show or Mike
birbigli that's one person show it's
like okay
Thriller and suspense is a sub-genre of
horror but it's still under horror so
like it's if it's a one-person show it's
still comedy and it's still quote
unquote a sub-genre of maybe stand up or
a variation of but like why should we
discount them because it doesn't fit in
the parameters of either what you do or
what you like
um I swear I'm not gonna just bash like
or talk ill that's
um I think comedians could really
benefit
from approaching a stage with an
optimistic view of wanting to entertain
the audience and that doesn't mean
pander but like
work like people took time out of their
day and their nights or whatever or
Friday or Saturday or whenever to come
out and see you at least give them the
pre at least give them the preparation
uh
I I saw an open mic this past weekend
where three out of the four Comics were
referring to their notes after greeting
the audience so they said hello I'm blah
blah blah and they went back to the
school and look at their notes I don't
know if that was because of nerves
or what but I was just like you don't
remember your first joke yeah I've been
going on some rants about these kids and
their notes on stage lately
Snappers you about triggered me right
there I tell you welcome back to two old
white men [__]
but yeah it's like yeah being prepared
being professional both yeah in your
material and like how you're presented
on stage I think all of these are like
little habits that really add up over
time as well that if you want to
separate yourself from every other comic
most comics
aren't thinking about how they look on
stage most Comics aren't actively
working on the material all the time
like when you when you get into the open
mic grind
you'll start to see a lot of the same
people doing the same things over and
over and over again
and there's a lot of ways you can start
to stand out from them and it's all work
and then the The Duality of that is
there was a Bert Haas who used to do
Zanies in Chicago who's Infamous for a
lot of different stories
um would say I don't ever see you do a
new five minutes until the five minutes
that you're doing is perfect
um
and so but there are a lot of comics
especially if you go to like local open
mics and you're seeing the same people
week after week they start playing to
the back couch of their friends or the
other comics and so they run into the
Catch-22 of never working on their
material because they're trying to just
entertain their friends who are seeing
them week after week
which there's a healthy there's a
healthy amount of working on your same
stuff over and over again and working on
new stuff and there's clinically and
scientifically a ton of different
approaches to that
um the probably the only bit of advice I
can give for that is try to get as many
shows out of state or an hour away from
where you're at
to do that to see to have a different
audience see you
because
they're not going to know who you are
they're not going to know your check
they're not going to know your jokes
so there's a little bit of Freedom
there's some weight lifted off of you
but uh yeah it's
it open mics and shows are are two very
different beasts and
I feel like there's a lot of young
Comics who are trying to nail the open
mics
but unless you're auditioning for
someone to get uh booked as a house MC
or for a weekend
I think an open mic is just about doing
your time and hearing out hearing it out
loud yeah saying it yeah saying it out
loud and and refining material is so
incremental so it's like like you said
the the guy from Zanies saying don't do
a new five until you have this one
tightened like till you have a type five
minute I mean you can refine material
not doing new jokes but just like you
have a new tag to an existing joke or
you have it instead of saying this word
maybe this other word is funnier here or
whatnot like you can tighten and refine
your existing jokes just by looking at
how you're saying them and what you're
saying and not necessarily saying oh
everything has to be new new but how can
I refine what I already have and make it
stronger and that's what's hard too and
like we are in such an age of the
hardest thing for stand-ups I think is
finding your voice but we're also in
this coexisting uh trying to Market and
brand yourself so how can you market and
brand yourself if you're still working
on finding your voice so you start
leading down a path that maybe is very
inauthentic and that's hard too because
you're still working on your voice
but so many young Comics
um
will are worried about filming their
sets
dude just to have stuff on social media
and to have crowd work where for me like
working on a joke I I contend when I'm
doing something new to talk fast
to be very excited to not articulate it
the correct way so I always suggest
doing audio recording when you're
working on new stuff because then you
can hear the response and you can hear
it how the audience is hearing you
because on stage you might be like well
I didn't get that laugh I thought that
was really good and then you go back and
listen to it and you're like oh I forgot
three words
that make it crucial to understand the
punch line and I didn't say it so so
yeah less focused on having content for
online
because the more you work on yourself
when you start filming those clips and
you put them online they'll be better
and you'll get a better response and I
know it's hard because these clubs and
Bookers are like what's your social
media follow ship and it's like meow
doesn't matter those people ain't coming
to the show anyway
yeah we're we're on
you and I are like where I I can't
imagine starting now because there's so
much more than just get on stage as much
as possible get as good as possible like
there's so much more that goes into
being a comedian now I can't imagine
trying to start now figuring out how to
make something funny and then also
record it like what's so funny dude I
did I did a show
I did a show this weekend and
um I the comedian the other comedian on
the show literally did this thing I see
like Mark Norman and like Sam Morel
doing it and like comedians are like
they do their set and then at the end
they do like all right yell stuff out
and I'll say funny things and then I'll
use it as clips and I saw this comic do
that
and it didn't work because they're not
seasoned and they exactly exactly
but it's their mentality it's tough to
like have now that's like oh I gotta get
clips clips instead of just get as good
as possible so I can't be this old head
like kids and their social medias it's
kind of part of the Hustle but it's like
get good and then have something worth
sharing
or get
get authentic to what you want to
present
so like yeah at least figure that out
yeah yeah and like and that is I think
again I think is the hardest thing but
know that what you're saying on stage at
least you are okay with or proud of
um I just had a show this past weekend
um where I open for a headliner in
Southern Kentucky
and we're talking about how
um I am not the kind of comedian that I
would go see
and that is okay
like my the comedy that I present in
stand up isn't all the facets of what I
think is funny
and that's okay but when you start a
stand-up set especially a headliner set
or a feature set it's a it's almost like
this is coming from my theater
background is you're approaching it like
a narrative where like I think there's a
beginning middle and end and where you
want to chunk your stories where
how are you starting what are you
talking about here where are you going
to end up like
I just and this isn't bitching about
young comedians this is about any
comedian is
some Comics are just as disillusioned to
some audience members where they think
that they can go on stage and just talk
off the top of their heads
and
I
anybody who thinks that Harlan Williams
or say like a Robin Robin Williams I
know I just named two Williams people or
Ian bagg people who look like they are
um doing these these crowd work and like
this impromptu stuff
they've performed so many times that
they're reaching back into a bag of
tricks and the stuff that they know that
works to continue to Pace in the flow
like they've put in their work too it
just they've made it they're so good at
it they made it look like they're doing
it on the spot right exactly that's just
a comment to like your Sam Morel of like
the crowd work and stuff they see these
clips of like say like um Steve
hofstetter where they're just like oh my
God he blew up on the Internet because
he had these altercations with crowd
work like if I could just have one of
those and it's just like how about you
just go out and
and present the comedy that you want to
present and then
we'll see what happens yeah amen
and um speak yeah and cheers yes
if we uh Glenn
tickle ass the question and uh tickle
Glenn tickle and uh O'Neill asked where
my Virginia show is it is in Bridgewater
Virginia at the Sipe Center
on Friday
so get those tickets now pull up on your
boy in Bridgewater Virginia
let's get goody
um
so Glenn asked
how much are we thinking slash
overthinking what jokes make the cut for
an album or special
holy moly
that is
nothing is worse because Glenn's just
getting ready to record his next special
that's still Stacks in Pittsburgh I
think it's the same weekend as as my
special in Michigan so if you got a pick
where to go between Michigan and and
steelstacks in Pittsburgh
um I think that's Pittsburgh uh or
Pennsylvania
is it New Jersey
oh I don't know I don't know
but if you're having to decide who to go
to between me and Glenn if you're going
to drive over a thousand miles or
whatever to see one of our shows go see
his
oh Glenn is phenomenal
um
I know with when I did dry bar and when
I did my first album which Glenn
produced
um or even my second album that I just
dropped of Comedy Dynamics it wasn't
even a week later that I stumbled Upon
A broadening of a joke or a better tag
or something yeah and I was just like
why like why did it not unlock until
just then but the fortunate thing is for
me the the thing I have to hang my hat
on is that I still have my My Life
Special to do so there's the album and
then there's the live special which is a
variation of the album so I can now
implement it but I know like Glenn like
you're gonna put together your your
special and even after that you're gonna
be like
I missed all of this all this gold
um
figuring out like what I've been doing
now since the album and thinking about
like what's going to be on the next
special is
and this this goes with anybody not
whether or not they have an album or a
special they're putting together when
they're trying to make the best concise
hour
is
I think almost like
rank the stuff
and if you're finding new stuff
that outranks stuff that there's laws
consistently
and you've worked on it you've tried
placing it in different areas of the set
you've tried rewording it and it's just
not getting the response that you want
even if you love it like you sometimes
have to kill babies
um I've mentioned this before there was
a caveman cereal serial killer bit that
I worked on for like three months that I
thought was very funny
and I'd work it and I'd change it and I
put it in a different spot I'd read did
everything
and I'd come home and my wife would be
like how'd the show go and I'd be like
caveman serial killer really ate a dick
tonight like it didn't work again would
you be like Ricky I know you think it's
funny
but when the audience countless times is
not giving you a reaction of telling you
it's funny you need to move on yeah and
I feel that doesn't mean that the idea
of like what you want to fill in that
slot or that spot
is like a lost cause
but I feel there is possible
um reworking like there's one bit that I
have about
um getting old or getting older and
different um things have happened within
the last year that were signifiers of
like okay now I feel like I'm getting
old I have old people stories
there were a couple that weren't working
so I started including different ones
not getting rid of but making the bit
longer
to see uh them fight one another
and so I do the new ones and I'd see if
those worked and then I do the old ones
and then I found out that the old ones
they still weren't working so then I
substituted the new ones that were
working with the old ones to still make
that bit like the five minute bit that
it is the consignment more concise
better working bit
um
yeah I mean the struggle of that is
there's a time where you're just gonna
have to let it go and that's the night
of the performance or the night of the
recording
yeah and just being honest with yourself
putting the ego to the side be like if
if it's not working it's only hurting
you really at the end of the day so yeah
you know at a certain point
just gotta face the facts and you know
it doesn't mean the joke is gone forever
you can always come back and revisit it
and and and in six months in three years
you may figure out what to do with it so
it's never there are so many jokes
there's a joke that I've been
workshopping that goes with the um the
getting older one and I'm I'm happy to
share it because I still feel like I
haven't cracked it
because I am primarily with dry bar
known as a clean comedian I get booked
primarily clean a lot of places they'll
be like well you can be a little bit
dirty or you can be more late night talk
show or or you can be r
but there are some places that were like
we went clean we don't want F words
we don't want gross stuff or whatever
sexual stuff and that's fine because I
don't really have that when I work clean
the only filter that I really put a stop
gap on is my spontaneous filter so like
some of my additional tags that I would
maybe add uh my impromptu
um but one joke in the getting old
segment because that's really what I've
been trying to uh
really hone in on and make tighter is
um I'm at that age now where I've had to
go to funerals
of people that I know that are my age
that have died
and it's really weird to see the same
person
um that was my age wearing the exact
same thing
in the casket that I wore to the funeral
but how
but how was I supposed to know that they
were going to wear I [__] on the first
date t-shirt
[Laughter]
that's a dirty one but like
the cleaner version which I've I've
tried is
um
go to the funeral and how was I supposed
to know that they were going to be
wearing the same thing that I wore to
the funeral in the casket I didn't know
that they were going to put them in a
crop top
and a pinstripe jacket from Men's
Warehouse
it doesn't hit as hard so is the joke
is it a good joke
or is it only good with the cursing
no I I mean the mystery
direct the the what they're wearing so I
mean it could be that you were naked or
it could be that they were wearing like
a toga or something like or yeah
yeah
birthdays yeah well maybe it's the word
economy how did I know that they're
going to wear a shirt that said pull my
finger yeah okay
I think birthday suit or pull my finger
are ones that I will probably implement
within the next month before the special
to see
because the crop top one I think it's
too many words and too many like hard
like crop top
I don't know
but it is is or just crop top have you
tried it with just crop top and not the
pinstripe suit
well so you when I've tried the the
Pinstripe uh jacket for Men's Warehouse
I usually go but how did I know they
were going to bury them in a crop top
and I hold
in a pinstripe blazer from Men's
Warehouse gotcha like and then I just
add that in for like the like well
they're not completely disgusting human
beings they put him in a suit jacket oh
right
but yeah it's I've done both versions
where I could go a little bit more blue
and say the the if on a first date shirt
and again it's that Jerry Seinfeld thing
of like is the f word getting the laugh
or is it the perimet like
yeah I think the premise because it's
all like a surprising shirt you're
wearing it's not the f word that's a
surprise it's like oh they're wearing a
t-shirt that says blank you know that's
what I think you could they buried them
in a t-shirt like that's ridiculous
and you're wearing a t-shirt at the
funeral so it's equally just as tacky
yeah yeah yeah yeah so there's like yeah
there's I think the misdirect isn't
about the f word I think it's just silly
what they're wearing in the casket and
what you're wearing outside of funerals
so yeah I think there's more than just
the f word you could do there
and it's a build on I'm sorry I didn't
ask if I was allowed to curse on this
podcasting you're you're just like in
the live cast
this is the family thing
no you're good
did you get a lot of bookings from Dry
Bar
um yeah I mean definitely of like any
kind of credit any kind of validation
where there is a separate entity that
says uh we took a chance on them
so you should
um is only beneficial
um and also you get to use those clips
as the best possible looking produced
clips that you can have true and there
is that again that just that validation
it's why I think I mentioned this on the
last podcast
I reached out to Glenn because I saw an
article about him self-producing and
coming up with the Zone label
um and I was like can you produce my
album and he's like and it's in the
article he's like the whole article is
about how I'm telling you you should
produce it yourself and I'm like yeah
yeah yeah yeah I want the validation of
someone else producing my album I don't
want to do it myself
so with that with like um I mean for you
doing dry bar you will use those clips
for me
I still use those clips or bookings
sometimes use those clip because of the
dry bar recognizable uh name but then
when I um
a 140 pound less Ricky shows up to the
show they're not sure how to approach me
either
um wow you look great or are you okay
yes sir
you're like smaller than the videos like
is this a fundraiser are we doing a
fundraiser now
142 gallons great man I I I have
definitely gotten bookings I've only
reaped the benefits of it and not all
the bookings have been like church
bookings or incredibly clean bookings
I do have because of it my favorite
[Music]
um
bombing
booking which was
um I got hired to close out a fundraiser
event for a children's hospital
I did not know I was closing out and I
did not know that the event started at 6
pm and there's been an open bar until I
went on stage until 10 pm oh they show
a 20-minute video of kids in the cancer
wing and an immemorium for the kids that
they had just lost in the year
before bringing me up on stage with with
like at that time and now currently
still a little bit my first 10 minutes
are talking about me having a
three-year-old daughter
and so it's like hey you know that video
you just saw about a bunch of dying kids
well I've got a live healthy one
that was you don't berate the audience
you've been paid for your work and how
much time do you have to do you have 30
minutes
if you don't have your phone in your
pocket because you're filming it because
you thought this was going to be the
groundbreaking viral video which maybe
it would have been and you don't know
how much time you've done you sometimes
have to ask what time is it and know
what time you hit the stage because you
contractually have to fulfill your time
and you get paid afterwards and you say
thank you and you leave what happened
did they just not laugh what was the
bombing they were so drunk they wanted
to be done they had been there for four
hours they didn't want to listen like I
my jovial like jokey butt was like the
last thing they wanted to see on stage
they wanted to go home they just did
their final auction before I got up on
stage and they showed that video
no one wanted to be there anymore
but
that's that's sometimes
yeah
the check cleared baby
oh that's the best
I love that
okay so I have another question here
from Jack Allen as well
um he asked if I'm doing stand up in a
new region which has a different accent
and I'm from elsewhere do I address it
at the beginning with a joke
uh before my usual joke
[Music]
um
I like my usual strong opening joke and
don't want to replace it with a weaker
region-based joke just to address where
I'm from
um I I so I looked at that question on
Facebook and
um through you and I talking it sounds
like he's from the UK and
so like originally I was thinking like
from the United States like I'm from
Northern Kentucky
and I do shows all over the United
States and when I talk about being from
Kentucky sometimes people are like oh
yeah I hear it in other people times
people are like
no idea
there are things that Comics do
that I get are
easy things to fall back on I'm not
saying easy like lazy
but whenever a comic goes let me tell
you a little bit about myself and also
this is all like
this is just my opinion
it's not comedy like written down in Ten
Commandments or whatever
I hate hearing a comic say let me tell
you a little bit about myself I'm like
oh good thing you told me that because
otherwise I'd have been lost and not
knowing what you were talking about when
you went into your pre-written five
minutes where you were talking about
yourself like yeah I get you're talking
about yourself
or when a comic says um well I'm about
ready to get out of here let me tell you
one last thing
who is that for
no one is like oh one last thing oh I
better listen up because I've been
loving this guy like
I get that those are sometimes like
nervous habits of like placeholders of
things to like write and stuff in your
template of your joke writing but like
so as far to as far as like your accent
if you have a strong opening joke
do your opening joke and if you can
make material after uh like after that
opening joke about the
the difference the audibly difference
between you and where you're playing
then do it if it feels natural otherwise
I wouldn't worry about writing a whole
bit to be like where am I where am I
playing tonight oh I'm in Alabama I mean
again this is going to be Continental us
like oh I'm in Southern Kentucky well I
better pull out my Southern Kentucky
material
now there is something to be said about
like
I know
where I can do some of my Kentucky
religious material
in some places that I can't
now when I did that material for my
album in Salt Lake City which is
heavily Mormon heavily religious could
be against anything religious I put it
towards the middle end of my show
and I presented it in a way and probably
not the best way possible but like I
presented it in a way that I thought
would ease the audience in that like
okay you've already got a sensibility of
who I am and like you like me right you
don't dislike me I think I'm feeling you
think my Approach is good or whatever
you're having a good time so then the
way I presented it I was like okay so
here's some stuff that may be considered
a little taboo
uh well the way I do it for at least for
the album is
I make the audience vote all right we're
at the point of the show do you want to
hear me talk about being from Kentucky
and how religious Kentucky is or do you
want to hear more stuff about my wife
people always regardless what their
reaction is pick about Kentucky in
religion
hmm
and so then I make a bit out of it so it
goes a little bit it's a little
antithetical against what I said about
the um berating an audience there's a
tightrope to walk of like if you get
into it and you feel their buttholes
clench you can then say be like you
asked for this we held a democratic vote
and like you can't be angry with me you
have to be angry with each other this is
civil unrest
like when you leave if you didn't like
this portion of the show you should
attack and go after the person sitting
next to you that like just jokingly
obviously I'm not trying to incite
violence
but then
I will then skew
if if it does get
too much of a lull or I get I dig myself
too much in a hole
even if I felt like it was okay to get
into that material
I then will pivot
in a way that I know what joke to go as
part of that religious material which is
again personal to me I'm from Kentucky
this stuff personally affects me
and I have a personal outlook on it I
then have a joke that is the end of that
chunk that I then can pivot into my next
chunk and it will seem seamless it won't
seem like I'm like bailing out of
something that I was like well this
isn't working I gotta Escape like but
again that's that's just me so no I I
wouldn't
I wouldn't address unless you're already
unless your opener is already
[Music]
um
commenting on where you're from
I wouldn't change what your set is but
also remember the longer that you
perform
the better chance you're going to have
of having to write a new opener
um
and also maybe a good exercise is
opening with what you think your killer
last joke is as your first joke
to work on coming up with a another
strong closer
yeah what do you do what do you do
yeah
performing enough for like being able to
Pivot in and out of material comes with
time as well like I think it took me
years to be able to start to call an
audible on the Fly based on the
audience's reaction you know so that's
that's definitely something that for
like younger Comics listening that you
will just get better at the more you're
on stage the more comfortable you are in
stage because then you'll instead of
just in your head about what's next
what's next what's next what's next then
you're actually performing listening and
like listening to the audience and not
like talking at them which a lot of the
early comedy is basically just that
you're just almost like reciting what
you have and hoping that it works
halfway
um but even for like what Jack is asking
like
if you're in your head about your accent
at this certain place it doesn't have to
be a joke it could literally be that
like I I traveled from I traveled from
Alabama to be here thanks for having me
and then you go into your first joke
it's like
it's just saying who you are where
you're from and then it's not a joke
yeah and it's not like too much of a
context and it's not too much of a let
me tell you a little bit about myself
like kind of thing it's just like if
you've heard a comic
if you've heard more than one comic say
something that you might say then don't
say it
because that is a real quick way of
shutting off an audience's ears of being
like oh this guy must be young this guy
must be new and it's okay to be young
and new but like for me like don't fall
into the tropes
of of saying those things because
so that's that's my whole opinion with
audience work too is when you ask if
you're going to ask the audience a
question
only do it if the audience's response
matters to where you're going
don't for me don't ask rhetorical
questions
because it doesn't matter it's just a
Time suck that you just wasted in your
10 minutes 7 minutes 20 minutes
unless it's such a rhetorical question
that you're making a statement that you
don't want an audience response but then
be prepared that
whatever kind of audience hears that
they're being asked a question that you
may be opening it up to
and then there's other rules if you're a
feature or you're especially if you're
an emcee you're not supposed to do any
audience work
yeah
yeah but those are like those Unwritten
rules
that just reminded me the comic that I
was talking about that did like all
right give me some topics like and then
it didn't work I remember him getting
mad at the audience I remember the
audience member yelled out taxes
and he couldn't think of anything funny
about it so then he got mad at the guy
for giving him a bad suggestion
it was hilarious like own it and be like
taxes my taxes are so depressing when I
do them and just be honest
because the one benefit you have with
when you open up to a q a or crowd work
which I've started implementing in a lot
of shows to try to help develop material
because an audience sometimes like I
said
the finding your voice and figuring out
what an audience thinks about you on
stage
um is really uh
uh hard when you're starting off
whenever wherever you're at in your
career
unless you're so big that like people
are commenting online and writing think
pieces about you you're not going to
know what an audience thinks of you but
if you do a q a
and you are just gonna earnestly talk to
the audience they're questions will give
you an Insight if you listen
to what they think about you
because you've inspired them to ask a
certain question like uh during the live
recording for the album in Salt Lake
someone asked do you have any more
weight loss stories
and I I Just Had An Occurrence a
situation when I was flying there on
Delta and I just told the story and it
got some of the biggest laughs because
it wasn't a bit it was almost like
improv do you know that like
that like easiness that an audience
gives you when you know when they think
you're doing it on the Fly
they give you so much more leeway to
like not be crafted to not be like
conscientious of the words that you use
and they think it's on the fly so
they're going to even laugh harder
because they're like oh we're hearing
this for the first time there's so much
psychology to it that an audience isn't
even cognizant of
that is is really interesting the
psychology of Comedy is I I think is is
fascinating
yeah how do you do
develop your material through crowd work
what do you how do you do that
so I mean like one of the the things was
um someone asked
um
because I tell a couple stories about my
family where they're like well what do
your brothers think of this I was like
oh my one brother works for Fifth Third
Bank a huge bank and makes tons of money
my other brother is a doctor and makes a
ton of money and I'm the lowly performer
comedian they're like oh yes please make
your little piffy jokes about us like
and I was just being honest of like how
I felt and how I felt they felt of the
situation of me doing humor now in all
honestness
I do a bit about my mother-in-law in the
show and that is since grown because
um my father-in-law passed away
unexpectedly in July
and my mother-in-law now lives with us
so that bit I had about my mother-in-law
has now expanded and become even more
personal but before doing it I asked her
I was like are you okay with me talking
about this
and she said yeah and similarly to my
wife whenever I've talked about
um introducing any humor or jokes about
her she's like I'm good as long as you
don't call me a [__]
in this old ball and chain right
and so like the stuff I do about my
mother-in-law is very um and I'm not
patting myself on the back it's just
very relatable
and there's an entry point access point
for most people even if you don't have a
mother-in-law that you have like any
issues with
um
but but yeah it's so as far as like
crowd work goes
I will take note of
what worked and if that opened up
something in me I mean me as a comedian
I started in 2005 as an open mic comic
that became a house comic at Newport on
the Levee Funny Bone in Newport Kentucky
and
from 2005 to 2009
I did not do personal stories
I did one-liners very uh Mitch Hedberg
very Mike Birbiglia very Dimitri Martin
based
um stuff
that I thought was funny and my
observations
and then it wasn't until I went and
lived a life in Chicago where I had a
period of not doing stand up as much and
then moving back from Chicago in 2017
where I started doing stand-up more
heavily
that I then was able to reflect on the
life that I had lived which experience
has a ton to do with it
um but like I started doing stuff that
reflected on my upbringing and reflected
on
um the schooling like the high school I
went to like we're the Campbell County
camels in Northern Kentucky
and our mascout was a camel in Kentucky
and our colors were purple and gold like
there was stuff that was like humorous
to me that we would joke about as
friends but that I never thought was
interesting to a stage
but then I started like curating it as
like a narrative and an act about myself
and I found that like oh okay people do
think that this is
entertaining or humorous like my goal
and I don't know if it's I I don't know
about you or any other comedians my goal
after the end of the show isn't to be
deemed as the funniest person that that
person has seen like I just want to make
that person have a good 45 minutes and
have a good time
yeah something that stuck with me
um was a comedian told me he doesn't he
doesn't want to change your mind he
wants to change your mood and I was like
I like that like it is just like them
leaving feeling better than when they
got there
yeah he's like it's kind of is like a
good goal and killing of course is fun
but it's like going in with that mindset
instead of putting so much pressure on
I've got a kill I've got a kill I've
gotta get a laugh every 10 seconds or
whatnot oh yeah you'll drive yourself
crazy for me so I love that quote of
like leaving with a with a mood of like
feeling good for me it's always that um
the concert mentality of like okay so
you go and see a concert and you see the
opening band and it's a band you've
never heard of the maybe half sets
covers but like it gets you into the
vibe of knowing what the night is we're
gonna focus at the stage we're talking
to our friends still a little bit but
we're the band is showing us that like
okay up here is where we need to look
this is where the show's happening
tonight
and then the next band comes on and they
maybe have one or two songs that you
like or that you maybe faintly have
heard of and you're like oh okay they're
drawing my attention a little bit more
I'm talking to my friends a little bit
less I'm into the vibe of the night
and then that final Act comes on it's
the ACT you came to see or it's the
closing act even if you got free tickets
or whatever
and you want it to roller coaster like I
I've had plenty of instances where I've
closed shows over our featured shows
where if what I featured people are like
oh my God you are my favorite person of
the night
like don't tell the headliner I've also
been the headliner in that situations
next to the feature where I've heard the
person because those people are also not
like delicate where they're just like
you are my favorite of the night
and I hear that I'm like awesome
I'm not pissed like you had a favorite
of the night great I hope you didn't
hate me but like
I I hope I will never be the comedian
who kicks off a feature from a weekend
because they do really well like that
should inspire me to do better
yeah for sure
yeah oh and John Mondragon said I'm the
same with women
yeah
I guess I I guess talking about not
wanting or leave them changing their
mood I don't know I don't know what John
was saying there maybe I shouldn't have
found them with women
my wife
oh my God so slight name drop I was
opening for Doug Benson
this was
a pre-pandemic and I did start a lot of
jokes with my wife
I didn't realize it
he stood in the back of the theater
because he watches everyone who performs
he doesn't just sit in the Green Room
for good and for bad
he sat in the back of the theater and
every time I said my wife is a preamble
for a story or a joke he went my wife
so we didn't have to have a conversation
for the rest of the weekend or anything
because I was like I'm picking up what
you're putting down I'm starting too
many stories or sentences with the
phrase my wife and so I will work on
that this weekend Oh and John said to
give them a good 45 minutes gotcha oh he
was being funnier than us
so um what as well as we start to land
the plane here you just released an
album you're about to record a special
you're also about to release a film a
horror film you're you're doing a lot
here Ricky
it's that pandemic yeah I mean that that
pandemic I think the one thing that like
people talked about was if you're always
complaining about not having time to
write that book and you don't come out
of the pandemic with that book
then you're just a lot of hot air a lot
of hot breath oh oh
so for me uh right before the pandemic
started
um I knew my my dry bar special was
coming out and I knew that my first
album was coming out right before the
pandemic hit and so I had also just
filmed a proof of concept for a horror
movie in March the week before the
pandemic hit and canceled a bunch of
shows
so we did our episode and again thank
you for promoting like I didn't have the
opportunity I was sitting on 300
physical CDs and a dry bar about being
able to like
to be able to do anything about it to
capitalize on it
um so your your podcast and your page
was the only thing
to really like let anybody know
um
it may be more people saw it because of
the pandemic who knows it kind of could
have maybe worked out for the better
like in that time though it felt like
oh what a great time to be releasing our
first album right and a special
but um what the pandemic did was
it taught me
to want to do
um whatever
uh what was important to me to achieve
and so um
someone who I made short films with and
had done a sketch comedy cable access
show with in college
we were sitting kind of as pandemic was
opening up in 2021 regulations and like
the protocol for getting more people
together what not were getting a little
softer
um we were like okay
as filmmakers what is one thing we would
regret 10 years from now
we're like okay based on the equipment
that we have is
what if we didn't make a sh what if we
didn't make a feature-length film that
we didn't push ourselves like I would
regret that
we get okay what would the story be
for that feature length film
meta based off of what the question we
just asked
of like what would a regret be for
people similarly our age for 10 years
before us and so
we came up with a semi-autobiographical
story about me who I'm someone who was
into theater and chorus and stuff and
Performing Arts but I also got hurt
playing football
and I was a state wrestler but we were
like okay what if I hadn't gotten hurt
and I was King [__] of turd Mountain
and had gotten a scholarship
for wrestling in Kentucky like what
would I have done and then maybe I've
gotten hurt in college
like okay well I would have been a
depressive possibly an alcoholic
um so we we constructed a story that
utilized
when we were talking about who could be
in it with the very small budget we were
like okay um we need someone who's
dedicated
and that there are a lot of scenes that
are just the lead actor and the main
cameraman the Director of Photography
which was my friend uh co-director Nick
Hance
and he's like well it's got to be you
he's like we can always depend on you
and I was like well I don't want to wear
that many hats and he's like that's what
we got to do for our first time out
so we wrote this story that was uh what
if and I'll use the long description and
then I'll use the concise description
what if the Breakfast Club grew Into The
Big Chill that went camping on a Friday
the 13th movie
hmm
so the more concise version which a
website came up with when we started
sending out the press release was what
happens when the teenage slasher movie
grows up
and as soon as a website came up that
subject line we were like we're taking
that now for our press release because
that is way better than the garbage we
wrote
um and that became the movie all your
friends are dead which uh we filmed in
we started filming with the majority of
the cast and we filmed the middle of the
movie that featured the most amount of
cast and we did it like a 48-hour Film
Festival
so crazily with no money
we shot like 32 pages of script which is
ridiculous to do in like one day
but we did that and then we put it
together and made a teaser trailer and
then did a Kickstarter and raised um
about ten thousand dollars which when
you clear it is about six thousand
dollars out of the fees that come out
and whatnot
and we made our movie and finished it in
2021 for
5959 dollars
which I say it costs that much but it
cost really ten thousand dollars worth
of favors
and then we were very coordinate for
some festivals to to play it it's a
horror comedy
um movie
and
I
incredibly low budget but there is
something interesting there with
this new wave of like Jordan peel not
comparing myself to him but like people
who came from Comedy that are doing
horror because comedy and horror really
run congruently
in the paths of like making them laugh
or making someone uh scared
um I think it does that pretty well uh
we got picked up by SRS Cinema
wait
which it's gonna have a shield you can
buy a special edition Blu-ray
until Thursday March 16th
so you have two days to get a special
edition Blu-ray limited numbered that
like if you don't get it now you're
never never gonna be able to get it it
is a special commentary that's only part
of that Blu-ray and you can get it on
the website that's part of the show
notes
or whatever okay exactly you're like and
the link will be in the show notes yes
yeah and I'll definitely because
yeah because you sent me the link and
I'll do it in the live chat now as well
for peeps watching live
that is
um I love performing I love entertaining
an audience
I really love
stand-up is lonely I love the
collaborative
nature of working on a film or working
with a bunch of people like a cast or a
crew and I think that can only help
someone stand up so like if you are a
stand-up like maybe try doing sketch or
improv and I know there's a lot of
naysayers
that will judge you and you'll be like
oh you're a stand-up and you're just
looking out for yourself like I did
improv Olympics and I know like it was
taboo like I never mentioned that I did
stand up because people in improv
Olympics and IO were like oh you're a
stand-up oh you're gonna be selfish
so I don't want to play with you but
like doing those things makes you a
better stand-up because it makes you a
better listener
and
even though Stand Up is lonely the
audience is that other component that
you can listen off of and feed off of
and figure out like how to hone and make
better your own stand up
yeah yeah and that's why you you do so
many different things and I think that's
important for us comedians is like we
can always we can get in Tunnel Vision
on just stand up stand up stand up but
the more creative things you do the more
skills you can learn I'm outside of like
anything in the Arts but the more skills
you can learn in general the more it's
going to help your stand up like it all
for me It All Leads back to stand up but
I've done sketch and improv and acting
and just writing copywriting and things
like I'll do a bunch of different things
and it all just strengthens your stand
up so I think having that diversity and
skill sets only where you think that
time away from Stand Up will actually
hurt your stand up it actually makes it
better and stronger and you you learn
new things about yourself and your own
creative process that'll actually help
your stand-up become easier
yeah I mean I think um again you with
the social media presence and the
writing groups of of hot breath like as
beneficial as it was to everybody else
who is in that weird
um Chasm of
of the pandemic like I can only imagine
that it also self I mean non-selfishly
and also selfishly for you was a way to
hold your feet to the fire of being like
accountable to right material and do
things like and that's okay it's okay to
do
quote unquote selfless acts that are
also selfish because there's no such
thing as a selfless act so like if
there's a comedian that like you you
like but isn't getting the stage time
and you give them some time
you watching them and watching them grow
is going is bound to make you
self-reflective and go like okay what do
I need to work on if I'm going to
criticize them or think about what
they're not doing that maybe doesn't
appease
my eye like can I step back and think
about myself and how I can I can be a
little tighter in some areas
um
well where can we and I'm gonna link
your your movie in the live chat but
where where can we see or hear your new
album and how about your your dry bar
like anything you want to promote please
let the hot breath verse know
all the promotion
um the new album is World's Greatest Dad
and then parentheses participant
and uh if you see the picture for my
first album it is a picture of my
daughter and I when she was six months
old wearing the exact same outfit
um
is my daughter and Me Now who at the
time of the photo was three
in a bathtub with bubble beards
so my idea is if if I continue to do
albums every album will feature here her
in a different stage of her life because
a a big part of the album is Me growing
as a person as a performer
and also the inspiration from her of who
I've become so I really want to feature
her until it comes the day where she's
just like no
or she's like
yeah where's my type
my joke is now is that I have my wife my
daughter and my mother-in-law living
under the same house that my next album
will be called estrogen and tonic
that is hilarious
hit this oh my gosh that's so good
did you say symbols yeah are you looking
for a sound cue for it to match up
that'll work does that mean that's a
little bit more churchy but yeah but um
[Laughter]
[Music]
but yes World's Greatest Dad participant
uh produced by comedy Dynamics
um is everywhere it's on Spotify it's on
iTunes it's Amazon wherever you listen
to albums um you can buy it from Target
which I don't know if that's
like the midwesterner in me but when I
saw that it was offered through Target I
was like oh my god I've made it
we're in the department stores well and
someone uh in Georgia who's a friend of
my wives
bought it from Target and it's the first
physical copy I had seen through a
FaceTime and I was like oh my God I was
like show me the back show me this like
I had seen everything but like because I
had to proof it but like I hadn't seen a
physical copy yet and I was like that's
amazing because I'm still like old
enough that like I like to buy physical
media of something that like I really
want it's like to see it physical
manifested copy that's not just through
clouds or The Ether or whatever
it's like again I've achieved everything
that I've wanted to achieve
like everything is just a cherry on the
top for what I thought like I could do
and I know like things are so accessible
and easy to do now that anybody can put
out an album anybody can put out a
special but like for me I'm just like oh
my God can you believe that I did this
and they're like yeah anybody can do
that I'm like yeah but I did it
um
it's
like have a distributor of the movie
that we made again for under six
thousand dollars
and have people that we don't know like
from the UK or whatever buy a copy like
we had um all your friends are dead was
in a festival in Austria
and I ain't people hitting me up being
like we found the movie hilarious and we
think the dark humor was hilarious
and that like touched me in a way that I
was just like
that's amazing
that like social that's what's good
about social media there's plenty of
that about social media yeah but being
connected like the the new form of pen
pal ism is what makes it cool and I hope
that continues and maybe some of the
negative uh aspects of social media
maybe get tampered down probably won't
um because the negative ones are the
easier way
to do things um but yeah follow me on
Twitter at Ricky glor on Instagram at
Laura Ricky Facebook Ricky glor comedy
wherever Google Ricky glor and you'll
find me I don't think there's another
person named me so I think I have that
going for that's the Bill Murray quote
from Caddyshack
got that going for me
which is nice yeah
oh well Ricky man I thank you so much
for
all you've done as well in terms of just
inspiring the next generation of
Comedians and leading by doing as well
and just all your kind words I'm
extremely grateful for
and
um thank you so much for taking the time
to even do this and I'm excited to see
your movie and I'm excited for your new
special to get taped and we'll
definitely be helping promote that as
well so
um congrats on everything man do you
have your uh Dry Bar Named
I do I think I don't know I mean I I
sent them a name I it hasn't been
approved or whatnot
um they basically sent me a first draft
yeah they sent me one I gave feedback
and then I haven't heard back since then
you are not the only one just remember
like an abused victim you're not the
only one yeah yeah I don't even think
about it anymore like and I had a friend
tell me
before I taped it that he's like just
enjoy the whole experience it's going to
be amazing he's like mine didn't come
out for two years so just know
like whenever it comes out just enjoy it
and be grateful but just enjoy the
experience and it'll come out when it
comes out basically so yeah and it's up
to you that if you want to look at the
comments on YouTube or Facebook if you
don't want to look at like I
I find that I am not a depressive kind
of person that I love looking at all the
comments and all the YouTube comments
and uh I have grown from some of it and
have leaned into some of it and
yeah I I the the whole experience of dry
bar they will do things like um they
included me
oh an election thing because I have a an
impression of um presidents from 1985 to
2020. they included me as part of a clip
compilation so that reignited some views
of my special and
it's it's awesome to like to just know
that that many people are seeing
um
your performance and yeah I wish you the
best of luck it's only going to be
awesome I can't wait till it comes out
because
I'm sure it's gonna be killer and
welcome to the dry bar family and
you will reap the benefits of all those
clips and
you'll watch a small bump in your
booking fee
yes oh don't tell my wife tell her it's
a significant bump in the booking field
well I mean it's hard like it's hard
like so many Comics don't want to talk
about the business side of things
but like it's a business like as much as
you're performing for people and want to
entertain them but like
you ain't doing this for free right yeah
yeah for sure
that's that's how I want to end I want
to talk about it we're both available
for booking for anyone that books and
runs shows out there like I'm going to
Virginia on Friday for a show from the
hopper at the verse Don Davis Womack
runs some shows up there so I'm gonna go
up there so anyone listening to this and
wants to book professional comedians
Ricky and I are both open for bookings
always available one one question that I
had before we go is how did you select
which notable comedy albums appear on
your back wall
are they you're like your top ten or are
they just pictures of images that you
like
um well these are all out these are all
actually um
let's see the Steve Martin one I can see
the red uh the um Jeff Foxworthy
yeah so there's um
um
the Seinfeld one
so it's uh that's that's Mark Lowry in
the back corner it's the first comedy
album I ever had yeah that's Jeff
Foxworthy Seinfeld Bill Hicks
Richard Pryor
and then Andy Kaufman George Carlin Sam
Kinison and Rodney Dangerfield yeah and
Steve Martin
um
and then
oh you can't really see it there but
then there's a drawing that a member of
the hopper at the verse Drew
um CJ
PJ Drew I can't show it in this angle
but um basically I picked the albums
um oh and then this one up here is a
wedding photo my wife is right in the
middle of all of it but um
I just picked uh
I like the albums oh and Chris Rock is
in the bottom right over here but
it's like a diverse
it was also like a variety of comedians
so like you know Mark Lowry is like
primarily in churches and then
Seinfeld's clean but then I have like
Sam Kinison and like Bill Hicks it's
like I just want to kind of do um
kind of a cornucopia of comedians but I
did like hand select all facets of you
which again like I mentioned when when
um I was talking from this past weekend
and being like well I wouldn't be a
comedian that I would go see because
like my favorite comedians are very
cerebral and like I am not a cerebral
comedian and like there is that
understanding of like being like that's
okay
like you have a lot of different
influences and you have tasted where
you'll go and stuff and that's okay that
you don't need to strive to be the next
whoever Chris Rock or Dave Chappelle or
you know whoever you don't have to be
that person but like figuring out the
best way to be the most Earnest you is
probably going to get you a lot of more
uh favor than
trying to sound like or be like somebody
else a hundred percent yeah yeah yeah
but it takes time to get to that
uh self-discovery and we all find it at
different times
for sure I think I'm trying to I'm
trying to focus on having fun again
and be a little more silly I feel like
I've spent 10 years trying to be cool
and then I think I've realized that I'm
I'm not cool and I've never been cool
and I'm more of a goofball and that's
fine
not to open a Pandora's box of a whole
nother thing is we're wrapping up the
show
when I started touring in a little bit
now my wife will be like um especially
when I first started touring more
heavily would be like all right don't
sleep with anybody like on the road and
like making it like a joke and then like
she said it like three times in a row of
leaving for shows for the weekend
and so it got to the point that it was
in my mind no longer a joke it was an
honest concern that she had wow and I
was like okay
you realize a majority of my show I talk
about you
yeah I'm talking about my daughter
and I end it usually by doing funny
voices
I was like in the history of doing
stand-up I have never gotten laid from
doing stand-up like the most that has
come from it is some dude Bros wanna buy
me a shot or have a drink with it but
like never has anybody been like and the
panties are off now me neither
yeah
that's my wedding ring just I was like
playing with it you're like making me
nervous I was like oh my gosh
but has your wife ever had those
concerns or ever voiced those to you
she's never voiced them if she did have
them
yeah she was she was never like oh be
careful out there or whatnot
I'm sorry she knows um you'd be such a
young buck in the woods you're gonna get
pounced on like Bambi's father
it's so interesting because like
I just have never there's never been
that kind of um rock star like groupie
mentality of afterwards of being like I
gotta add them to the list of people
that I've slept with like
oh yeah oh man dude I want to go to bed
I guess
a little bit of bad food
yeah if I do goodness I mean if the
show's at 10 o'clock I was like man can
we do a matinee this is late
I'm gonna go to bed
Papa's Got to sleep I gotta take a
melatonin and go to bed I can't I just
gotta give us late hours I gotta get
eight hours yeah that's that's that's
where I'm at for sure
nice
all right everyone thanks for hanging
out live or listening to the podcast go
follow Ricky go get his album go watch
his movie
and just tell him that you heard him on
hot breath and you appreciate his time
and we can keep doing more cool things
like this but Ricky man I really
appreciate you so much I'm excited the
the hot breath versus brought us
together and I'm excited for what we
both do together in the future
thank you sir keep on doing what you're
doing
absolutles
hot breadthiverse have a great day we
love you
bye
bye y'all